hello and welcome back to New rockstars
I'm Jessica Clemens and we're still all
riding that high from across the
spider-verse all those fighties oh
please give me more but I don't think
each of these Spider-Man will play a
major role in across the spider verse
but clearly there's some like Jessica
Drew Gwen and Miguel will spend more
time focusing on then there's May Javi
and the villain spot that we didn't even
really see in the trailer but we'll also
be playing prominent Parts in this
character breakdown I'll be breaking
down the 10 characters we'll focus on in
their functions in the movie Spider-Man
2099 AKA Miguel O'Hara isn't necessarily
a Spider-Man more so a spider-ish
experiment in the comics he worked for
alcamex which we saw in into the
spider-verse he was drugged by his head
honcho in charge Tyler Stone and in a
rush to cure his Newfound addiction from
that potent drug he was sabotaged by his
other supervisor Andrew Delgato and his
genetic makeup splice with a spider
giving him enhanced reflexes super
strength Talons fangs and the ability to
shoot webs from his arms from across the
spider verse what we do know is that
he's starting a spider Force this
includes spider Gwen and safe to assume
Jeff Drew and hobby as well from the end
credit teaser from into the spider-verse
Miguel talks with his Ai and it's safe
to assume they might have built these
bracelets for himself and the spider
force and the spider Force members are
the Spider-Man in The Citadel of spideys
we saw in the trailer he's been jumping
universes recruiting everyone his AI did
say you may be the first person to make
an autonomous Multiverse jump with his
prototype bracelet that everyone
seemingly has now they must be tech
savvy because he shoots these electric
energy-based webs instead of his normal
webs we've seen so far as most spieties
lose their Uncle Amaze Peters what have
you Miguel's probably lost his daughter
who we see in the trailer under file 011
Gabriella the tunnel that Miguel and
miles are also fighting on says Rapture
the name of the drug that was given to
Miguel in the comics it also has an
inverted text of alcamex at the top of
the tunnel safe to assume his home in
Nueva York like in the comics is sort of
run by alchemix I think ultimately like
in the comics Miguel's biggest obstacle
and plan of attack is alchemics and
keeping the other universes safe and
fair he's super driven and thick headed
so safe to assume that this one goal
will be his driving for course for
everything he does in the movie even if
it means cracking a few eggs along the
way and by eggs I mean miles is back we
also have Hobie Hobart from Earth 138
who was an unhoused teen turned Kick-Ass
punk rocker Anarchist Spider-Man who in
my opinion is the most rebellious Spidey
he was bitten by a radioactive spider
made by a legal toxic waste dumping and
spider Punk was basically
anti-establishment against big
corporations he fought for the lower
class those forgotten in the downtrodden
he was the leader of the spider Army and
he led his supporters to Rally against
his universe as president Osborne and
then he smashed his head in with a
guitar he then joined the superior
Spider-Man's Army and recruited more
spideys from across the spider verse
what we do know about Hobie is that him
and Gwen have become very close friends
based on interviews with Lord and Miller
and it makes miles a little jealous from
what we know in the comics and Miguel's
history I bet Hobie joined immediately
because taking down massive conglomerate
seems like his ml plus he probably rocks
out with Gwen all the time so I think
it's gonna be great to see him in this
role so now we have Spider Woman Jessica
Drew now in the comics Jessica Drew
Hales from Earth 616 because she's not
not really a Peter Parker she's not even
really like a Spider-Man she's her own
thing in the comics her father worked
alongside Herbert Windham if that sounds
familiar it's because of the high
evolutionary and when Jessica got sick
he tried to save her by injecting her
with the untested serum made with the
blood of you guessed it spiders this
doesn't make any sense they're like oh
she's sick let me just get some spider
blood and the 2015 Spider-Woman run is
where we actually see Jessica pregnant
and still fighting crime to take care of
her son financially and as a good role
model to him from across the
spider-verse what we do know is that
Jessica Drew is based on the run during
Secret Wars based on what Lord and
Miller said in the interview I think
more so this is like that she's pregnant
and that she's a pi then fighting
Scrolls like she did in the comics
because there's a part before that where
Jessica stops fighting and this Jessica
hasn't really stopped one looks up to
her also as a mentor so they're probably
working alongside each other she's
probably a part of the spider force and
has a close relationship with Miguel as
well just by the looks of this scene
from the trailer Jess can also shoot
webs out of her fingertips which is
actually pretty insane because not a lot
of Spider-Man can do that I know Cindy
Moon can still but not a lot came can we
know Jessica is indeed pregnant but we
just don't know who the baby's
biological father is yet but it could be
Miguel I kid or do I she's fighting what
could be her universe's vulture so her
Universe could resemble this artwork
which would be breathtaking I think that
Jess is not ready to give up fighting
just yet it was really hard for her to
stop and adjust so suddenly in the
comics as well so she'll be fighting and
supporting the spider Force up until
that last contraction her motives
otherwise are unknown for now it's
winter and I'm pretty sure I'm not the
only one who's jealous of bears who get
to just hibernate their way through
several months of cold a bear's life is
aspirational if you want to come even
close to I could sleep from now until
the spring thaw you're gonna need a
helix sleep mattress Helix sleep makes
premium mattresses embedding customized
to fit your needs and shipped right to
your door knock knock who's there it's a
mattress and look I'm not a sleepologist
and I don't need to be because Helix has
a sleep quiz that matches your unique
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you you can even
take with your partner and find the
mattress that's a perfect compromise
between your preferences and I know
that's hard to find because I like
things hard and he likes things soft
context I took the quiz I wanted a
medium firm mattress with lumbar support
that sleeps cool and I got matched with
the dusk Luxe Helix mattress I've had it
for a few months and I absolutely love
it I sleep better and I wake up less
often he always delivers your mattress
right to your door for free and it's so
crazy because it's the heaviest mattress
in the world and they delivered it
straight to my house and I'm so thankful
for it it comes rolled up in a
shockingly tiny box it is super easy to
set up yourself because all you have to
do is open that box and it explodes
Felix has a 100 night sleep trial so
you'll get more than three months to
make sure that you love your mattress if
you don't they'll pick it up for you and
you'll get a full refund these
mattresses also have a 10 year warranty
that's an entire decade if you can't cow
Helix even has a financing option and
flexible payment plan so a great night's
sleep is never far away I love my Helix
and I think you would too if you're
looking for a new bed check out Helix
you can click the link below or go to
helixsleep.com rockstars and get up to
200 off your Helix mattress
for vitro private care aka the
Spider-Man from India of Earth 50101 who
moves to Mumbai with his own Uncle when
he later runs into an ancient Yogi that
gives him the powers of a spider to
protect others and use his powers for
good he joins the army of spiders during
spider verse then later the web warriors
with spider Gwen and Spider-Man Noir
from across the spider verse what we
know about this character we got a look
of his Universe in the first look for
across the spider verse referred to as
mombotan Lord and Miller said we're
going to spend a good amount of time
here it's a whole ass reel and we know
reels are usually like eight to ten
minutes I think he will be another
member of the spider Force but he feels
like the closest Spider-Man akin to
miles and I wouldn't be surprised if
they started a friendship though miles
is not a member of the spider Force we
also have the spot AKA Dr John own from
earth616. he was tasked to make a
machine for Wilson Fisk that would clone
the radiation levels of cloak to mimic
his powers that's when he walked into
the funky machine he made and it
destroyed himself you think people would
learn after Dr Manhattan you know Haley
just walked in there and exploded but
anyways though he did go in there gave
him teleportation and multi-dimensional
Powers his weakness his spots he needs
his spots to teleport so if he's out of
spots he's out of luck from across the
spider verse what we know about the spot
is he will be the villains Banning the
two-part movie so he'll probably
accomplish what's needed in the first
movie and then into the second one in an
interview with total film Kemp power
said the spot is an interesting villain
because he seems like a joke but when
you really look at his powers there's
incredible potential his ability to open
portals across Dimensions sets him up
perfectly for the spider-verse and let's
just say that the spot and miles are
connected in surprising ways could this
be an alternate miles could this be an
alternate Jefferson we don't know what
makes it too close because we haven't
seen them go at it yet but it's best to
keep that noted not much is known about
spot except for what the producers and
directors have said so his true
villainous ways are still up in the air
ultimately beating him shouldn't be hard
for the spideys which is why I think
there's still a bigger power here at
play that we just don't know yet I
wouldn't be surprised if we see Doc Ock
or Doom taking over for alchemix and
higher in the spot we also get spider
Gwen Peter B Parker miles and Mayday now
you know spider-gwen Peter B Parker and
Miles so I'm not going to give them any
real introduction but we're going to
talk about what they're going to be
doing in this movie from across the
spider verse what we do know is they
mentioned that Gwen was invited to join
the spider Force while miles was not
they also add long distance
relationships are tough especially
across universes so just don't expect
this relationship to be on Solid Ground
which I think is a good note there will
ultimately be a lot of heartbreak in
this movie in an interview with total
film director Ken Powers also said the
unique dilemma of being Gwen Stacy she's
a vigilante seen as responsible for the
death of her world's Peter Parker the
cop in charge of tracking her down as
her father this sort of follows her edge
of spider-verse spider-gwen run where
she has to face off with her dad who
thought the exact same thing Peter B
Parker now has a baby and rekindled his
love with MJ and we've seen Mayday
Parker because they just released some
photos of her and she does have Spidey
Powers this Miles Morales is much more
prepared than the models we saw in the
first movie but could that Newfound
confidence be going straight to his head
I think it's good to know because we
don't know where he's going here lastly
people forgot that there is gonna be an
introduction of Takoya Yamashiro of
earth51778 and across the spider verse
it could simply be a design but if it's
anything more good to note that Takoya
got his Spider-Man powers from gorea an
alien from planet spider who gave him
the spider bracelet and Spider-Man
extract making him the Spider-Man but as
of right now not much is known except
for Japanese Spider-Man is making an
appearance that's what's that for our
spideys and across the spider verse let
us know which one you're most excited to
see down below in the comments follow me
on Instagram and Twitter at Lulu
underscore Clemons follow me Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars from our
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching Spidey out I don't think he
says that
foreign
[Music]